multi-trillion dollar asset manager
fidelity is all in on bitcoin they just
published a brand new research paper it
is titled bitcoin first why investors
need to consider bitcoin separately from
other digital assets this large asset
manager made it very clear they believe
bitcoin is something very different than
all other 15 16 000 cryptocurrencies in
the digital asset ecosystem they
specifically stated that bitcoin is a
monetary good it's one of the primary
investment thesis for bitcoin as they
store a value asset they think that it's
fundamentally different from everything
else there's no other digital asset
that's likely to improve upon bitcoin as
a monetary good and also any other
attempts at an improvement will
necessarily face trade-offs now of
course it's not necessarily mutually
exclusive between the success of the
bitcoin network and all other digital
asset networks but understanding that
things outside of bitcoin are trying to
do something else is an important piece
for new investors as they come into the
industry then they go on to state that
non-bitcoin projects should be evaluated
from a different perspective bitcoin can
be considered an entry point for
traditional allocators looking for
digital assets and investors must hold
two distinctly separate frameworks for
considering investments in bitcoin and
other types of assets now this is a big
big deal why because we know that
bitcoin the trillion dollar asset we
have a multi-trillion dollar asset
manager that now is going all in and
saying pay attention to this they then
go on to go ahead and compare the
various assets of gold bitcoin and fiat
currency they compare these assets
across durability divisibility
fungibility portability verifiability
scarceness and track record and as you
can see right there in the middle
bitcoin is superior to gold and fiat in
every single one of these perspectives
except for track record so ultimately
fidelity calling out bitcoin as a
monetary good why is it superior to
traditional historic monetary goods and
then we have this great quote from their
piece they said the invention of the
wheel represented an entirely new
technology that once invented could
never be reinvented similarly never
before in human history had the problem
of digital scarcity in a true
peer-to-peer electronic cash been solved
until bitcoin was invented solving this
problem was not merely an incremental
improvement but a leap forward or an
unlocking of the puzzle of how digital
scarcity could exist and then they
finished up with this great graphic as
well that virtuous cycle or reflexivity
of bitcoin where basically as bitcoin
continues to get more users and holders
there's higher demand which equals
higher prices which brings in more
miners which increases the security
which makes bitcoin more attractive
which brings more users and holders that
reflexivity as you know from historical
financial markets when you find it and
you're able to actually hold it it
usually turns out pretty well it's
absolutely incredible to see a
multi-trillion dollar asset manager like
fidelity not only in the bitcoin which
they have been for years but to be
publishing reports like this and so
clearly articulating what their thesis
is and trying to help other traditional
asset allocators on wall street and
elsewhere go ahead and figure out why
they should have exposure to bitcoin as
well